back in the days with rapper juice to
start off we used to have to borrow the
jury before we could purchase it so
that's why you hear a lot of rumors
where they say you don't own that you
don't own this you borrowed it back in
the days you say that a lot but it was
true that's not a bad thing it's just
you got to sell yourself like Cinderella
you never mate
what's up y'all this Slick Rick on the
rocks please
well I've been in the security game for
a minute since the very beginning you
know on who knows before people like me
rocky romare bearden cats it was like
mr. t so mr. T was our role model before
us so this is where we come from we call
from the generation after mr. T so like
my first piece of jury was like a ring
like this one you know this cuz it's for
like the mid 80s so it still looks like
you got money but you only got one piece
of jewelry you know the ring so that's
why even look at my first pictures you'd
always see me with one ring or a
bracelet cuz I had I didn't have all
this stuff yet once your eyes are
exposed to a certain level of jury
extremeness you always want to reach
that level you don't want to go back to
the bottle you want to go to the top
this one I got because I started getting
bigger
you know this door was big or something
makes an impression when I started
getting some money I got the ice in it
to make it look even better
cuz when you like perform I like me and
stuff you're further away you I you know
I look it stands out like this you're
some sense oh now you can see it and it
makes an impression it's like a Sammy
Davis jr. type of thing and I mean big
joints
[Music]
here's my wife brought for me she gave
it to me on my 40th birthday kind of
looks like a military design I get with
this one which is a little bigger a
little better arms are bigger so it
looks better on your face it's something
this is you know is unique because
nobody wears our iPads so when you put
this on your face it really says jewelry
like what the heck it's a creative idea
to get an eyepatch you know Vanessa
stole your pirate look you're me this is
a watch that I wear when I'm mingling
with the upper le you know maybe we all
get to to crazy on our mean so you just
drop one of little joints and you go
like this and you just mingle with them
like this does a little little eyes will
suit I'll oh that's classy though it's
got a classy look to it you know me nice
a Bronx CA all right so this watch is a
Rolex
it's from the ladies early night got
this from Jacob the jeweler it didn't
have so many rings on it my first board
and then you just keep going when you
get money you know and this is
conversational piece you know how you're
moving urban neighborhoods you got to be
large so that people you could be like
this in the man you know who that over
there without big eyes watch on oh that
[ __ ] is a problem you know this is one
of my first bracelets I got this from
Jacob the jeweler - mr. Barba this from
Jacob until I purchased it then I didn't
own this yet even this anissa's know I
had to borrow from Jacob till I got some
money then I purchased it as time
involved you got to get bigger as you
see this is a styler came out later
which made this look tiny
you say oh say now you walking around
like this you ain't getting no you get
no respect and legs away yeah and look
like give it to your girl so you get
bigger like this so when you put them
all together like this on your arm that
looks like one giant big bracelet you
know science that makes an impression
especially I want a short sleeve shirt
you know then it's like hot you don't
want to want to overload yourself just
one like where one piece like this one
it's this big it's in your face you
can't miss it
just throw a chain on it and just
dangler like this and call it a day like
that this one I brought from Chinatown
New York Chinatown
it was the biggest piece in the window
it was sitting in the window for like
years
nobody was purchasing it
I assumed that it was a drug dealers
plate and he got arrested and he
couldn't come back and pay for it so
they just stuck in a window it was a
Libra plate I'm not a Libra I'm a
Capricorn but it was so big and it made
such an impression I had to have it
smell like a little paper so I put some
ice on it and I changed the Libra signs
of balance like a scale like balance
like relationships balance and you know
balance harmony balance stuff like that
so it's like that I don't finish I'm
still gonna put some more ice on it
later as the chips come in you know as
far as gold I'm all I like I like the
rose gold because it's new now all gold
is still good you know I mean sometimes
you could dip gold chain and turn it
rose gold you know me or whatever a lot
of these rings used to be gold and they
come from the mid 80s early 90s and then
I just dipped white gold yeah they look
more expensive but at one time they was
all gold like like this this is too
inexpensive and you're going on like
this
this piece we've had for like 20 years
15 years sometimes I stay ahead of the
time I knew this type of stuff was
coming it's supposed to be the symbol of
the agent symbol of young Yang's right
here I didn't get to put the circle here
and there but you know you get the point
looks like Pepsi was really supposed to
represent the yin-yang thing you know I
mean this supposed to represent two
hearts couples spouses it takes two to
make a thing go right type thing you
know I mean this triangle represents
like the pyramids all the way back to
the Egyptians all that stuff I designed
this one myself well I bought the desire
to the jeweler and I told him can you
make this and that's how we remove a
shake like that it's it's long it's long
but it's next chain I had to take off
the jacket so you could get the effect
yeah this is one of my earliest pieces
this is mother Mary comes from way back
it called it a house medallion used to
have the red ruby right there something
I just want to lay in the cut like this
you know me don't summarize what someone
said you look bro just casual say that
and this was also the biggest one they
had also in the store in Chinatown the
same place that had this one buggy I got
both of them
this is the eagle I really also worried
cause it was the biggest thing moving in
the store at the time and this chain is
call like a bow
me and LL Cool J is two ladies type of
stuff back in the day this was called a
Gucci link this one also comes from the
80s this one has a lot of history the
Gucci link and you see like rappers
right now with modern Gucci legs
together it's a lot bigger and more
unique and they put ice on it and stuff
like that so this plate is a scorpion I
got this when I was in LA one time I
went jury shopping and it's the biggest
thing they had the goddamn story [ __ ]
you know same so I was like god damn you
know me so but I still bought it I guess
I was bored young I'm bored I'm a
Scorpio evil by the way so yeah and this
is a fever job or Nazareth's I don't
want to get the name wrong you know it's
one of the other I like religious stuff
so there you go
this I also got from the diamond
district Ace of Diamonds I mean they put
in blue stones it didn't mean nothing
was just the biggest [ __ ] they had in
the store and get like I said it was
beer it was big it was nice I needed to
step my game up you know mean I say give
me a [ __ ] I know you need some more ice
to fill in the gap just get like I'll
put this on right now right like this
it's cool right but now it needs a plate
or you gotta fill in this gap so these
to fill in this gap so it looks like
that until I can afford this you know
this piece was across a lot of people
have these back in the days like didn't
have this back on it it was just across
as I started getting money I put a nice
back on it so it would have a better
effect so now I work to the same guys
that made this piece and I told him put
this on the back of this it was a simple
it stupid he needed some so they put
this back on it and gave me a nice
powerful effect everybody so now you can
wear it all by itself like this but you
will put a my scripture on the back
Psalm 23 I guess they got bored and just
did it you know nice guys please this
one also comes from that there early
it's just hard not a very nice heart
room there was a couple to restore that
has some really nice stuff that costs a
lot but was lit like this at that time I
wanted to make that type of an
impression but let's say if I was in the
Hamptons so you come with the rings and
the regular nothing else on antenna
because the conversational piece in
eight is not now now it's like this
sticky game well tell me the jury of
today or the younger artists today is
very expensive you know I mean now
you've seen a watch game and little
little pieces they look little but
they're very deep things you could tell
it's very expensive you know the range
so that's the involvement of the game
you know I mean this is my generation
before them
this is today's generation it looks good
on them you know it depends on Holly
where we howdy swag get up you know it
looks good like me goes you know they
keep it up here like this you know so
they can see when you sitting now me
preferably if I'm not sitting down I
like my [ __ ] to drape you know me
it all looks good when it's all together
like it looks like a cluster but if it's
just by itself now I can't you can't
wait this by itself
anybody get into the jury game I will
give them the advice of like a
Cinderella story
you start off broke and then you you
involved like that but don't waste time
on corny [ __ ]
you're already like if you really broke
you buy like a gold bracelet and then
you dip it into like rose or ice yummy
and then you know and then you just keep
all moving like Cinderella like that you
know me you know you got one a little a
little Cuban link and still be working
and still it still adds to your charisma
[Music]
the best fear of all time I would have
to give it to myself I would also give
it to French man tablets watching got a
mean watch I would give it to puffy cuz
he comes out sometimes with some some
expensive [ __ ]
Gucci man sometimes cause I was on my
shades wife to come out some expensive
[ __ ] busting rocks and toss it girl shut
it down when he's ready you know Kanye
West when he when he's ready plays you
know me to chains when he's ready he
comes out with a giant piece you know me
when I first came home then he first had
to ring something like this and it would
just sparkle in my face like this every
minute I said nice tie my god damn game
so I went and got this I got I got one
for me and my wife got one too it's just
something you know when you when you
just doing some low-key [ __ ] like this I
said and you just want to look normal
but still look a little flashy did this
go together like this so saying like I
got to add the plane wedding bands to
you know like you really got to give
some boring as place how about a night
that's about all I could tell you family
[Music]